last week i published a conversation
about the origin of life with dr david
fialo
after we stopped recording david started
talking about information
what it is that's meant by information
or should be meant
when people are talking about
information in the origin of life and
information
in biology in general what type of
information is being transferred when a
chain of nucleic acid is being copied
and how do we quantify that information
and so on now
when we started in on this topic i
realized hold on this is important and i
stopped him and i asked if he could
start over
so i could record his thoughts on this
issue
what you are about to hear is i believe
one of the most or maybe the most
important conversation that i've had on
this channel so far
it really was fascinating information is
nothing magical
in physics it's often described simply
as that which resolves
uncertainty and i understand that even
this definition sounds a little bit
magical a little bit woo-woo
the word uncertainty here sort of
implies a mind
being involved but information transfer
happens all the time
without minds the universe physicists
often say
is an information processor when
bits of matter interact with each other
information processing
is one way to think about that for
example if a bus
smashes into a wall it transfers
information about its velocity
and density into that wall and vice
versa
the wall's quote uncertainty about the
mass and velocity of the bus
has been resolved to some degree it now
has a crude representation of that bus
in its own structure the hole that's
left or the crater that's left there
is a crude representation of that bus
likewise when you take in information
through your eyes
that is a physical interaction it's
purely physical
light is hitting your retina and it's
leaving its mark on your retina the
nature of that impact is then
transmitted to your brain and is
it affects the structure of your brain
really this is physics
information transfer is really it's just
a physical interaction there's no
woo-woo here
when we're talking about the replication
of a chain of rna
we're talking about the transfer of
information about its sequence
the parent chain of rna transfers
information about its sequence
to the daughter strand of rna how many
bits of sequence information are
contained in a single chain of rna
how accurately can this transfer happen
these are some of the questions that
david
cares about it turns out that claude
shannon
back in 1948 while attempting to solve
problems in telephone communication for
the
bell phone company he actually produced
all of the equations that we need to
quantify exactly how much
sequence information a chain of rna can
hold and
how to quantify just how accurately a
given replication system is
at transferring that information to the
next generation
of rna chains now claude shannon of
course was not talking about rna but
everything he did is directly applicable
if we would just use it it's all laid
out in shannon's paper a mathematical
theory of communication
and it's just waiting for biochemists to
pick it up and
yeah apply it to their own work though
david and i don't really talk about it
much in this conversation
shannon's equations can also be used to
describe the information transfer that
happens between
rna and protein you know in in the heart
of the ribosome the process
of translation in biology please forgive
the
recording quality of this conversation
again it was done on the fly
at one point the sound goes a little bit
shallow
i guess you could say we lose for a
moment some of the richer undertones in
david's voice
this is because his apartment door was
wide open when an airplane blasted by
when i say blasted i mean it was so loud
that i had to filter it out
in post because i was worried that
someone might go deaf
if they were listening to this
conversation on headphones that said
even with the filter sufficient data
makes it through for you to receive
and process all the information that
david intended to transmit
this really is an important little
conversation david is a careful thinker
and always aims to be precise in
communication i've listened to this
conversation several times now while
editing i've even stopped and worked out
some of the equations
so that i would understand it better and
i'll probably listen to it several more
times after it's posted it really is
that valuable without further ado here
is dr david fialo
talking about sequence information
information entropy
and information transfer at the origin
of life i think it's especially
egregious in the field of prebiotic
chemistry that when people
use this word information
it's not clear exactly what they mean by
it and
different people often mean different
things by it
i think it might actually impede
progress
okay i think that a certain definition
of information would be useful in
understanding the origin of life
but because so many people use it
flippantly
it will be difficult to convince others
of the legitimacy of one definition of
it
yeah that's what i'm going to try and do
right now though okay
so um in the simplest sense
let's just take a computer as a model
system
yeah a computer stores information how
does it do that well it does that with
bytes which are composed of eight bits
each
each bit is one of two possibilities
which we call zero and one
it doesn't really matter what the exact
identity of that
possibility is but it matters how many
of them there are yeah
so uh one bit
is one unit of information
yeah uh one byte is eight bits
how many different possible bytes are
there
there's 256 because every single bit
in the byte has two possibilities
they're all unique so
2 to the 8th power is 256.
so if i were to say
how much information would i need
to specify 256 different states
the answer is one byte or eight bits
okay the mathematical definition of that
is that
and this this is strictly mathematical
but it's useful in certain cases
the information of some random variable
[Music]
is just the logarithm to whatever base
you want
of the number of states possible by that
a random variable
assuming all the outcomes are equally
likely now
biologically we can we can interpret dna
and rna that way
yeah unlike a computer where each digit
has only
uh two possibilities rna and dna each
digit which is a nucleotide has one of
four possibilities
right so that means that in dna
there are two bits per nucleotide
so if you have 100 nucleotides you have
a
200 bits of information
but then there's there's an auxiliary
meaning of information
which is important for replication
suppose i know the sequence
of a template strand of rna okay
and suppose this template strand of rna
replicates with a certain fidelity
in other words it makes mistakes every
once in a while
and what do those mistakes
do to the predictability of the
sequence of the daughter strain they
make it more difficult to predict
what the sequence of the daughter strand
will be so the lower the fidelity
the lower the predictability for
information to be
transferred there needs to be
uh non-zero predictability
this uh this concept is
totally formalized mathematically and
was done so most elegantly by claude
shannon
he called this concept information
entropy
but to me in this context what
information
in the context of replication really
means is that
you have the reasonable ability to
predict the sequence of the daughter
strand
based on the template strand right
that's what information really is and i
think
i don't want to go too deep into the
math but the point is that it can be
quantified
and there are i think that there are
certain principles that are important to
the origin of life
that can be mapped out mathematically
rigorously
yeah but other people they may mean very
very different things by that
yeah so when lauren williams talks about
information
and i think when sarah walker talks
about information
i know that when when lauren williams
talks about information he's talking
about
information transfer between unlike
molecules so you
so he is thinking of information the
same way as you but in the genetic code
he's thinking can you predict the
protein sequence based on the
rna sequence um yeah that's right yeah
and so it's that that he really cares
about
if that's correct if that is exactly
what he thinks
that is totally
uh amenable to the same mathematical
interpretation that i just said
have two random variables one is the
sequence of dna the other is the
sequence of the protein
the mathematical treatment would be the
exact same right
right and i and i actually i believe
that sarah walker's um
she she's really interested in the
communication between unlike systems
so she sees life as layers of
communication it's my understanding of
her position and her and i have talked
on twitter but
we haven't talked in person talking to
different researchers there does seem to
be a
yeah communication errors because people
are using the word information
differently
i have seen quite a few people talk
about it in a shannon
fashion so but some people find that
definition insufficient because they say
that just because you have a bunch of
sequences available
doesn't mean that that necessarily codes
for any function but
the retort i would give to that is that
i'm not excluding
that at all i never said that that
wasn't important
i just think that the strict
mathematical definition of information
is something that we should state
explicitly
and we can move on from there right
right if you have a long enough
if you have a large enough group of rna
molecules
that have a random sequence one of them
is going to have a function
to do something and one of them might
have a function that helps it better
survive and replicate in that specific
environment that you've set up for it
so function is really just when we talk
about function all we're saying is
is this thing somehow able to maximize
its fitness
better than its neighbors that's really
what we're asking in biology
so the function yeah function is a
different thing from information
yeah definitely like i said uh when we
were talking earlier that
from my point of view the thing that
really exists is just
replicators that have the ability to
modify their local environments to
different extents to maximize their
fitness so i think
broadly what function really means is
just the set of ways
a replicator can interact with its
environment right
right yeah and that's not yeah that's
almost orthogonal to the concept of
information yeah
yeah it really is separate and and the
same you know when we
when we're you're designing a computer
you design a computer
so that it's capable of transferring
information faithfully from one part of
the computer to the other
you don't worry about what that
information is going to be it's for the
user
when we're trying to discover an
evolvable system
that could develop functional entities
you know that that's all we care about
is this
is this thing replicating faithfully
enough to transfer information from one
generation to another
without catastrophic failure where you
lose all fidelity
uh yeah and and that threshold is going
to change
like how hard it is how faithful it
needs to be i think is going to depend
on
how long the polymer is right how long
the chain is
yeah so we could
we could go down a rabbit hole with this
but uh um
so if you have if you define a fidelity
per nucleotide and obviously
for longer sequences the fidelity will
be lower right let me just
make one point and we can decide okay
how important this is but uh
a lot of the time in prebiotic chemistry
we're trying to make oligomers and one
of the biggest problems that's perceived
in prebiotic chemistry is how apparently
difficult it is to get really long
polymers yeah chains i yeah chains
i actually don't see that as a problem
and i think that all of the experiments
that have ever been done in prebiotic
chemistry
that all tend toward the conclusion
that the oligomers tend to be short is
something that we should accept
and embrace yeah and i'll tell you why
all right i hope i can explain this
adequately
suppose that you have a self-replicating
molecule that's 20 nucleotides long
right it has some mutation rate
it suppose the mutation rate is kind of
high so that it's unlikely
that you'll ever get a perfect copy of
this 20 nucleotide
thing so that's
that could be a problem but consider
this what if we split that
20 nucleotide replicator in half into
two
10 nucleotide replicates
now the probability that
any one of the copies of each of the 10
nucleotide replicators
is 100 correct that probability is still
low
but here's the thing if there are
repeated rounds of replication
and the daughter strands persist
throughout these repeated rounds of
replication all you need to happen
is for in one of those rounds one of the
10 nucleotide
replicators gets it right and in any of
the
any other round the other 10 nucleotide
replicator gets it right
yeah whereas in the 20 nucleotide
replicator case
everything needs to be correct in the
same round of replication yes yes
so i think that it's actually it makes
more sense that the oligomers would be
shorter
at the beginning because it's more event
it makes more sense to have
small cooperating replicators than large
high-fidelity replicators
okay yeah yeah let me let me try and try
and rephrase that so
you're saying that one of the problems
in origin of life that a lot of people
think is a problem
is that we're only getting short chains
to form
so we're getting like we're getting
between 10 and 20 mers with the proteins
with the peptides
you're saying that's not a problem
because the other problem that we have
in origin of life is that replication
early on is not very faithful because
like in
a modern cell you've got all kinds of
really highly evolved enzymes and
proof reading and all sorts of things
that happen in the genome of an organism
to make sure that when the dna is copied
it's copied faithfully
you do not have any of that in origin of
life before
and those are all evolved structures so
just by default replication would have
sucked
back then yes and so you're saying that
if you have a lot lots of short
polymers lots of short chains that are
able to replicate
because they're short their chances of
being replicated perfectly is a lot
higher than if they were long
not only that it's like as long as
they're cooperating
they could accomplish the same perhaps
the same function as a longer
replicator could but they have a much
higher chance of
coexisting with the correct sequence
right right so
cooperation is key here and some people
might think oh cooperation that sounds
crazy well
if you look at a genome today we have
genes that are all stuck on one
big long chain and we actually have
enzymes that break them out individually
in much smaller chunks so we already see
in life we have a lot of cooperating
smaller systems
furthermore we already know
mathematically how cooperation evolves
this is this is
something that's been really really well
worked out uh if you look at the work of
stuart west
and other people it's a big thing in uh
at oxford
where they've been studying this for
years like cooperation
when you have entities that can evolve
they can
you know descent with modification acted
upon by selection
it is very common for them to evolve to
cooperate with one another
and so i i and i don't think
i totally agree with everything you said
so i don't think that cooperation
necessarily needs to be anything
that sophisticated it could be as simple
as like
if two strands of a nucleic acid
have one section that is complementary
then
just at that section they'll bind to
each other
and there's a lot of evidence that
suggests that when
self-assembly occurs resistance to
hydrolysis
is conferred so all i could cooperation
could just be as simple as they agree to
stick together and they'll both
have a higher chance of surviving if
they stick together it could be that
easy
yeah because because they happen to
stick together
they happen to be stronger and sturdier
they get when they get bumped around
they don't break in pieces that's it
absolutely that's
that's that's cooperation yeah that's
really
fascinating so yeah the cooperating
small molecules makes a lot of sense to
me
and and i think that really does solve a
lot of problems here so
yeah i think a lot of people are going
towards that right now in their research
so
yeah all right well cool david that was
a fun little
uh little little mini conversation here
yeah dude i really enjoyed this so
thanks